a man in Hawthorne California there was
a police incident and a bunch of people
were outside videotaping some cop cars
and the police officers and well now
we're going to show it but really it is
quite graphic so let's take a look
that's for the ground like the dive the
guy wants a common edge and the dark
comes make your dog is the doghouse
how many hours
oh don't miss
okay that does not get easier to wash no
matter how many times I wash it at this
point all right so it's unclear exactly
why the man was being arrested it's not
illegal to videotape police officers
while there there's an incident
it seemed bizarre that they immediately
handcuffed him just like that
and then the guy had the dog out he
actually put the dog in the car the dog
jumped out of the window so it wasn't
like he was trying to SiC the dog on the
cops and then as you saw the cop shot
the dog several times okay there's so
many levels with this story involving so
many things so I actually I'm just gonna
where do you want to start with this one
Vanessa I mean where do we start if you
see earlier in the video first I don't
even know why the man was arrested he
was just right supposed to be about he
wouldn't turn off the radio he had any
success at best and best turned down
music that's supposedly what it was but
he did turn it off when he put the dog
in the car and they just did walk right
up to him and immediately the rest okay
so we're already off to a bit of a
sketchy start I mean look I think if you
unfortunately I did see the video a few
times and I and I really paid close
attention to the dog's behavior um yes
he responded as any dog by the way my
dog would respond it the exact same way
if I've got five six people in all black
you know manhandling me doesn't know the
situation uh the owners handcuffed so
there's no way for him to you know tell
the dog to calm down or grab the dog you
can see him trying to command the dog
and tell you know the dog does obviously
doesn't know English so he's not going
to respond to just the owners commands
and what I want to know is you know look
I look I love police I'm not like anti
you know I think they're amazing I think
they put their life on the line to
protect and serve so let me just put
that out there right now but in my
personal opinion as a citizen I think
that deadly force should be the last
resort and I feel like in this video it
was the first resort yeah do you know
what I mean I think that if indeed this
officer was threatened you know
physically or felt like he was
physically at risk then there were a lot
of other options that should have
happened that could have happened before
ultimately going to shooting
why could he have pepper sprayed the dog
why couldn't he have tried to contain
the dog even with his leg even with what
I mean there's five six officers if he
were there by himself arresting somebody
just with the dog and the dog was Viton
you know that's a different circumstance
but it wasn't there were like six cop
cars a SWAT car I mean I'm ready for
Will Smith to walk out of the house with
the a.k like look like a movie yeah I
mean I talked about having backup so
right so I'm with you on this because
there are many other options and it's
very easy for us all to always gang up
on the police and if you look at all the
comments on YouTube yes everyone's
immediately attacking the police there
clearly was some level of threat but are
you on board this idea that there were
other options available or that it just
escalated too quickly that no there
wasn't even a moment of really trying to
corral the dog in any other way and
should a cop be put have to deal with
that or did it I mean I heard an account
of it before I watched the video and I'm
glad as horrible as it is that I watched
the video because it does escalate
quickly and the dog isn't at fault than
the owner isn't at fault of course he
left the windows down because it was a
million degrees on Sunday and I can see
the pod officer got scared and reacted
really stupidly and it's so upsetting um
it comes down to pepper spray something
do something else other than shoot it
war times yeah and this is also show how
humans you know there look it seems to
me that there was some racial element
going on there because the the the man
himself seemed to be egging on the
police a little bit in the way he was
Seattle like a little bounce in his step
in videos having them and then they were
walking hood and there seemed to be just
some sort of like he's dealt with police
in this in this element before but then
look who pays at the end of the day with
the innocent animal and and maybe the
cop will now pay I mean look if you if
you take a really close look at the
video as unfortunately I did the dog
retreats many times I mean he'll start
to go but then he'll come back on the
curb and if you see right before he was
shot the cop actually lunged towards the
dog before he went up to finally try and
bite him and I think that's not okay you
know so like I said deadly force should
be in my opinion the last resort and I
feel like in this situation it was the
first resort and I think that it was
bad judgment in his you know in that
moment I don't know if that's just under
training I don't know if it's just maybe
this guy's trigger-happy abused abuse of
power I mean four times to shoot an
animal you know maybe even if you just
shot him once as like a reaction or he
could say I didn't even realize what
happened but four times yeah I mean it's
it's really just bizarre that everyone
knows there being look they went into
this knowing that they were being
recorded already because the guy was
recording them does that make it even
weirder that these things can still
happen when everyone knows they're being
recorded all the time yeah you would
think you would think they would dial it
down or have some sense of this
apparently this man showed up and
started videotaping because he'd had
civil rights violations by the police
and Hawthorne in the past that was even
something I heard that maybe it was the
same officer that had roughed him up
there's a couple of completely who knows
um but you would think then especially
if these officers recognize this guy and
it's being videotaped by so many people
that there would be some sense of
decorum don't shoot a dog yeah don't
shoot a dog all right well I mean I
think clearly we're all on the same page
here and it is not an easy situation and
I have certainly have empathy for the
officer too because it's a bad situation
he got put in but I guess this would be
a good time to jump on my soapbox and
tell you adopted dog instead of buying
your dog we are all dog adopters here we
discovered before the show and there are
so many great dogs that are ready to be
adopted and and the mills are killing
it's a whole other thing
we'll do that on another show Larry
let's see